an esteemed collection of actors have
played batman over the decades and
robert pattinson is the newest to join
their ranks how is his bat suit distinct
from the others keep watching for all
the tactical distinctions
adam west michael keaton val kilmer
george clooney christian bale and ben
affleck have all had their own versions
of the bat suit if not multiple
variations on it batman's gear is an
integral part translating the more than
80 year old character from comics to the
screen while costume designers get
considerable creative license on other
productions comic book adaptations have
to walk a fine line between translating
costumes that look great in the
fantastical worlds of comics into a
realistic film version
what gives you the right what's the
difference between you and me i'm not
wearing hockey pads
what did costume supervisor dave
crossman and concept artist glenn dillon
do differently for the batman pattinson
who originally screen tested for the
role wearing a version of the val kilmer
bat batsuit told entertainment weekly
about his official costume i felt very
different immediately it really flowed
it was so well designed so articulated
on all the joints it was kind of
shocking you're trying to get under my
cape doctor as cool as the bat suit
always looked freedom of movement has
not always been high on the priority
list for the costume designers
pattinson's version of the suit makes
some accommodations for that it has a
collar at the top of the cape around the
neck while this may look strange to
comic book fans it gives batman
protection around his vulnerable neck
area while still enabling him to turn
his head in his own interview with
entertainment weekly the batman director
matt reeves explained part of the
tradition is that when you're playing
batman you don't just do an audition you
do a screen test and they need to see
you in a bat suit but they don't make
you a bat suit because that's a very
involved process so what you do is you
put on an old bat suit pattinson
struggled with the heat and the lack of
movement in kilmer's version the costume
that was custom made for him by contrast
was almost too comfortable patinson told
ew in the costume fitting i ended up
doing loads of somersaults and stuff and
then they added all those into the fight
scenes you can do like a couple of
somersaults in it but it really gets old
pretty quickly reeves and his design
team seem to have ditched the solid
rubber of past bat suits adopting
something resembling an actual battle
suit it all fits with the director's
vision of a more realistic gritty hero
fighting for his life crossman and dylan
worked hard to echo that sentiment in
the suit pattinson told ew there are
little blood stains on it there's kind
of grazes where it's been hit with
bullets and kind of just the wear and
tear of someone who's been out fighting
every night it looks like a soldier's
armor in some kind of strange parallel
universe where you have to wear little
ears on top of your head as well but
what about batman's all-important
gadgets
while batman's comics costume places the
majority of his gadgets in his utility
belt pattinson's batman has a more
modular and tactical approach with
devices and weapons built in everywhere
he said the grapple gun is i think in
every single batman movie but i'm not
sure how many times he used them so
defensively it's used as a weapon it's
kind of based on travis bickle the gun
mechanism which he has in taxi driver
there is also apparently a unique use
for the bat symbol on his chest we can't
wait to see pattinson explained it's a
tool which he can pop out of the chest
plate which is kind of amazing
incredibly difficult to design as well
and looks great wait like in superman 2
probably not there also seems to be a
gadget hidden on batman's leg during a
chase scene with the penguin batman
causes him to flip his car there's a
visible bulge on batman's right thigh is
it a weapon a gas mask like soldiers in
the field carry we'll find out when the
batman comes to theaters march 4th 2022
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
the batman are coming soon subscribe to
our youtube channel and hit the bell so
you don't miss a single one